appeasement never works and tonight we
have yet another damning reminder the
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu is now sounding the alarm and
as per usual
the Prime Minister has pure moral
clarity I've been saying this for years
now the Prime Minister is revealing
according to thousands of pages of
official documents obtained by
intelligence sources Iran's nuclear
weapons program is alive and well the
Iranians call a project Ahmad it is
secret it is illicit it is an ongoing
scheme to construct nuclear weapons and
the means to deliver them including a
very specific plan to develop five
warheads each containing a ten kiloton
yield now here's what the Prime Minister
Netanyahu said about this program in an
incredible press conference incredible
bit of intelligence earlier today this
was Iran's chance to fully come clean to
the IAEA they could tell the truth they
could say we had this program the secret
program it's over we shoved it it
doesn't exist we destroyed the material
here's what Iran actually told the IAE
it said Iran denied the existence of a
coordinated program aimed at the
development of a nuclear explosive
device and specifically denied that this
specifically denied the existence of the
Ahmad plan the material proves otherwise
that Iran authorized initiated and
funded project a month a coordinated
program aimed at the development of a
nuclear explosive device
here's another document from the archive
this is a master plan a project Imam
Ahmad I'm told the Prime Minister did
all of that an entire presentation
PowerPoint without any notes now
remember this comes just three years
after President Obama signed off on what
is the worst deal in the history of the
United States frankly the world that was
the multilateral agreement where the
United States agreed to unlock 150
billion dollars of frozen Iranian assets
and send another 1.7 billion in cash
including an initial 400 million
down payment literally shipped in cargo
planes in cash you know the currencies
now some critical US sanctions against
Iran were lifted at the time what did we
get in return a promise from radical
Islamic mullahs of Iran that they
temporarily halt their nuclear weapons
program the same mullahs that actively
planned for the destruction of israel
the same mullahs the chant death to
America death to Israel that fund
terrorism all over the world that are
fighting proxy war after proxy wars in
Iraq and Syria and elsewhere the same
mullahs that are responsible for killing
US soldiers in Iraq holding other
Americans hostage remember Obama told us
well this was good for the world but we
warned you this agreement was always a
sham no different than when Neville
Chamberlain declared peace in his time
and signed off on a deal trying to
appease Adolf Hitler no different than
when Bill Clinton appeased Kim jong-un's
father Kim jong-il and the agreement
Clinton promised this is a good deal for
the American people it will halt North
Korea's nuclear weapons program and
ambition once and for all and in 2015
Obama wanted you to believe once again
if only we kissed the rings of desperate
sand and radicals and dictators somehow
they're gonna be nice to us faulty
failed logic appeasement never works
President Trump now faces a very
important decision whether or not to
hold Iran accountable and pull the us
out of this deeply flawed agreement
here's how President Trump reacted to
these incredible breaking developments
today in seven years that deal will have
expired and Iran is free to go ahead and
create nuclear weapons that's not
acceptable seven years is tomorrow
that's not acceptable
it's a horrible agreement for the United
States including the fact mr. president
that we gave I ran 150 billion dollars
and 1.8 billion in cash
Nigeria would like some of that 1.8
billion in cash and a hundred and fifty
billion dollars you know we got we got
nothing we got nothing so that doesn't
mean I wouldn't negotiate a new
agreement we'll see what happens but
I think of anything what's happening
today and what's happened over the last
little while and what we've learned has
really shown that I've been 100% right
there are moments in history you have to
learn from and the devastating failures
of appeasement Neville Chamberlain Bill
Clinton in his day President Obama in
his way it all has taught us appeasement
never works peace through strength does
work this brings us to our next topic
president Trump's historic diplomatic
progress on the Korean Peninsula now
instead of trying to appease Kim jong-un
or bribe him with both loads of cash
President Trump took some very tough
measures now in the early months of the
administration remember the president
increased sanctions on the North Korean
regime
he said multiple Carrier Strike groups
to the region he squeezed North Korea's
most important strategic partner China
all the while calling Kim jong-un little
rocket man and saying our button works
the media freaked out proclaimed Trump
is going to lead us to a nuclear war he
said the same thing when Reagan called
the former Soviet Union an evil empire
we knew better and now the president's
strategy is now seeing significant
progress that is great for the world
because for the first time ever this is
his start look at this Kim jong-un
crossing in the South Korea for this
historic positive meeting with South
Korean president moon and a meeting
between President Trump president moon
and Kim jong-un is moving forward as
planned not done yet certainly good
progress and also breaking today
according to the two South Korean
sources the North Korean dictator is
willing to give up his nuclear weapons
program completely as long as the United
States agrees to officially end the
Korean War and promised not to launch an
attack over the weekend during a rally
in Michigan well the crowd reacted well
this is when the president was gonna be
at the White House Correspondents Dinner
and I'm proudly in 30 years of radio 23
years on TV have never been to a single
one I'm proud of that this is how the
crowd reacted to the developments and on
the Korean Peninsula take a look I
remember you know was very rough 3-4
months ago
that's very nice thank you that's where
no bail
I just want to get the job done I just
want to get the job done everyone in the
fake news media their heads just
exploded now get this the South Korean
president agrees moon is now echoing
these calls for president Trump to in
fact yes receive the Nobel Peace Prize
let's hope he can pull this off now
these historic and rapidly evolving
developments from the Korean Peninsula
should give everyone around the world a
sense of cautious optimism and some are
even calling presidents from a
transformational president three words
peace through strength we'll bring you
more on this later in the show but first
the deep state is crumbling right before
our eyes nearly five years ago then
National Intelligence director James
clapper remember he blatantly perjured
himself in front of Congress you may
remember this moment does the NSA
collect any type of data at all on
millions or hundreds of millions of
Americans no sir
it does not not wittingly there are
cases where they could inadvertently
perhaps collect but not not wittingly
and of course a short time later what do
we learn the NSA was collecting data
clapper knew it and he lied he was never
charged like general Flynn with lying
this case perjury and now clapper has
been caught in yet another bold-faced
lie
and according to a report from the house
Intel committee during a closed-door
hearing clapper flatly denied ever
discussing that pony Clinton bought and
paid for steel Russian dossier with a
member of the media he also repeated
this claim in March during an interview
with Don Lemon over at CNN take a look I
didn't have any contact with media until
after I left the government on the 20th
of January so I don't quite understand
at least what I've read that somehow I
leaked about the dossier so let me get
so you didn't leak anything about the
dossier to any media no not I mean I
talked about it after I left the
government but not during that period
not and certainly not between the 6th of
January and the 10th when the
president-elect himself talked about it
an incredible development now the Intel
committee's report found the clapper
quote admitted to the house permanent
Select Committee on Intelligence in
private testimony that he briefed CNN's
Jake Tapper in early of January 2017 now
this was shortly before Trump's
inauguration Tapper along with two other
journalists so-called journalists from
CNN published a report detailing how
Trump was briefed about the steel
dossier and then a short time later
James clapper oh he was hired by fake
new CNN as an analyst you connect the
dots
president Trump reacted on Twitter
writing quote clapper lied about
fraudulent dossier leaks to CNN he's a
lying machine who now works for fake new
CNN now if clapper does not face legal
jeopardy over this blatant perjury to
Congress it will be yet one more example
of what I say is our two-tiered system
of justice he'll go with the Hillary
Clinton system of justice now let's turn
to the mainstream media if you thought
they couldn't get any more anti Trump or
downright vulgar think again they outdid
themselves over the weekend the White
House Correspondents Association held
their annual dinner I am so proud I've
never been where they take some time to
honor the media pat themselves on the
back just like their Hollywood buddies
for their courageous work of echoing
each other now president Trump who did
not attend previewed the dinner at his
rally in Michigan he decided to stay
with the people just like he did last
year good choice by the way by the way
by the way is this better than that
phony Washington White House
Correspondents
I could be up there tonight smiling like
I love where they're hitting you shot
after shot these people they hate your
guts shot and I'm supposed
and you know you get a spot and if you
don't smile they'll say he was terrible
he couldn't take it and if you gotta be
a mile they'll say what was he smiling
about you know there's no way
now presidents Trump's description all
too accurate this year's show features
so-called comedian former Daily Show
contributor I've never heard of her
before this weekend Michelle wolf
delivering a performance that's so
cringe-worthy vile and so one-sided well
you might want to cover your ears if you
have kids in the living room tonight
take a look Mike Pence is also very anti
choice
he thinks abortion is murder which first
of all don't knock it till you try it
and when you do try it really knock it
you know you gotta get that baby out of
there you guys got to stop putting
Kellyanne on your shows all she does is
lie if you don't give her a platform she
has nowhere to lie it's like that old
saying if a tree falls in the woods how
do we get Kellyanne and under that tree
suggesting she gets hurt just stuck
evanka cleans up nice
she's the diaper genie of the
administration on the outside she looks
sleek but the inside it's double not
even funny if you think that's bad by
the way
wolf saved her worse remarks for Sarah
Sanders who was sitting just feet away
so to a few feet away take a look and of
course we have Sarah Huckabee Sanders we
are graced with Sarah's presence tonight
I have to say I'm a little star-struck I
love you with aunt Lydia on The
Handmaid's Tale
I actually really like Sarah I think
she's very resourceful like she burns
facts and then she uses that ash to
create a perfect smoky eye like maybe
she's born with it maybe it's lies and
I'm never really sure what to call Sarah
Huckabee Sanders you know is it Sarah
Sanders is it Sarah Huckabee Sanders is
it cousin Huckabee is it anti Huckabee
Sanders like what's uncle time but for
white women who disappoint other white
women by the way Sarah Kellyanne about
they all took it with incredible grace
especially Sarah Sanders right there
this the performance or so-called
performance was so bad so mean-spirited
that even the association's president
expressed regret over Wolf's were marked
and some of the mainstream media even
they called out this so-called comedian
take a look I think that the comedian
crossed the line and this went from
poking fun to being mean-spirited it was
very uncomfortable I think that Sarah
Sanders handled herself very well about
you know journalism and and not the red
carpet not the mean-spirited jokes that
we saw last night some of those I really
thought were inappropriate this dinner
has had a lot of bad moments I was
thinking back last evening as I was
watching this cringe-worthy performance
in some respects going after the
appearance of Sarah Sanders which I
thought was inappropriate I really
thought that the pain of the people on
stage when Sarah Huckabee Sanders was
being made fun of I everybody felt pain
for her she felt pain and it really
bothered me and I know there's big
controversy about whether or not her
appearance was being made fun of her not
come on by the way it Fox News Alert
Hannity agrees with mica anyway just as
the president tweeted this event is now
dead now the president was incredibly
smart not to dignify this dinner with
his presence
Sarah Sanders other Trump officials
attended in order to show their
appreciation for the press and the vital
function that they serve in this country
and they were promptly mocked and
degraded the press deserves no such
consideration going forward I've said it
before I'll say it again journalism in
this country is absolutely dead
journalist their opinion advocacy
Haute's they don't admit it our last
story tonight comes from our southern
border for weeks we have been tracking
this large caravan of migrants from
Central America as they march through
Mexico headed to the u.s. border Mexico
does nothing and now dozens of migrants
have arrived at the border and they're
demanding entry into the US with some
attempting to scale a border fence in
California President Trump
weighed in also earlier today take a
look we are a nation of laws we have to
have borders we're not borders we don't
have a country and I've been watching
for weeks as the caravan came up and you
know the Mexican laws are very tough on
immigration extremely tough and it
started out with way over a thousand
people I guess now it's down to about a
hundred you gotta have a wall and we
need border security and we will have
border security as you know we're
sending many many National Guardsmen
down to the border most of them are
already there and that's having a big
impact but we need a change in the law
where's the Mexican government they went
all through Mexico and by the way they
usually imprison people from Central
America El Salvador Nicaragua and or
they just return them and deport them
immediately now for decades they've
turned it all too obvious blind-eye is
millions of their citizens as well as
citizens from other countries show no
respect to our law laws our sovereignty
our borders our citizens this is an
issue of national security an issue of
u.s. sovereignty
Mexico needs to be held accountable and
most importantly it's time for the wall
to be built on our southern border